As author Jenny Han has said, 'P.S.
I Still Love You is about the reality of really
loving somebody and not just falling in love
with somebody.
This is the part of the story that you don't
often get to see in movies, which is what
happens after the couple gets together.'
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm breaking down how LJ made her
crucial decision at the end of P.S.
I Still Love You.
There will, of course, be spoilers, so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet.
LJ may be deliriously happy at the prospect
of their first date, but reality doesn't live
up to the fantasy of her romance novels, and
things don't turn out quite as perfectly as
she imagined.
Lara Jean finds Peter's goofing around at
the restaurant a little embarrassing, and
the moment feels less special when she discovers
he regularly took his ex, Genevieve, to the
same restaurant.
"For every first I was having with him, he'd
already had his with her."
LJ also feels let down by Peter when she finds
out that the Valentine's Day poem she thought
he wrote specially for her was actually written
by Edgar Allan Poe.
And then there's the way Peter turns up hours
late for a coffee date with LJ as he prioritised
sports practice over her.
But the issues they're having with their relationship
aren't entirely on Peter, because when Lara
Jean unexpectedly receives a letter from childhood
crush John Ambrose, emotions and feelings
she didn't expect to have any longer rush
back to the surface.
"I thought having a boyfriend meant the mere
idea of other boys left your mind completely."
As Lana Condor, who plays LJ, told EW,
"[John] is kind of like the male version of
Lara Jean.
Everything she loves, he loves."
For example, they're both House Hufflepuff,
which LJ once thought could be a sign they
were destined for each other.
Lara Jean doesn't know how to handle these
old feelings and memories, and tries to suppress
them by putting away the letter she's writing
to John Ambrose.
"Oh my God.
I cannot do this.
Do I have to tell Peter about this?"
But when she meets him again and reads her
original childhood letter which mentions their
shared embarrassment during a Halloween party,
she remembers how close she felt to him.
"I love you John Ambrose, I really love you.
I'll always know that once upon a time, my
heart was yours."
As she explores these emotions, Lara Jean
realises she feels much more comfortable around
John compared to the constant worrying she
feels and overthinking she does about her
relationship with Peter.
"But if Peter was sitting here and we were
sharing an ice cream sandwich, I dunno..
I'd be thinking about has Peter shared an
ice cream sandwich with someone before?
Does he think that I'm a prude if I just wanna
share an ice cream sandwich?"
"I just need a break from the contortions
of being someone's girlfriend."
The developing love triangle creates problems
for Peter and LJ's relationship when he gets
jealous that she's spending time with John
Ambrose at Belleview.
It's no coincidence that this comes up in
the middle of a biology class during which
the teacher talks about octopuses having three
hearts.
And there's a clever bit of foreshadowing
of their break-up when Lara Jean dissects
the octopus's heart in front of a squeamish
Peter.
Things come to a head at their old treehouse
haunt where Peter gets possessive and John
finds out that LJ and Peter are together,
something she hadn't told him.
Peter complains LJ shouldn't be hanging around
with her ex-crush, an accusation that seems
a bit rich given the amount of time he spends
with Gen.
Although they patch things up, they argue
again later about Peter's close relationship
with Gen, and LJ has the heart-breaking realisation
that on the night of the hot tub, Peter was
actually waiting for Gen, not her.
LJ's mistrust of Peter is too deep and they
break up at the aquarium, which was hinted
at earlier during the octopus heart scene.
Ultimately, the root of their problem is the
secrets they've been keeping from each other.
Their intentions weren't necessarily bad,
as each was trying to protect the other.
Peter keeps the time he spends with Gen trying
to help with her parents' problem hidden from
Lara Jean because he knows there's bad blood
between them.
And likewise, LJ keeps her feelings for John
Ambrose to herself out of fear of hurting
Peter.
"I thought that if Peter and I were together,
the two of us could get through anything.
I was wrong.
But I do know we weren't honest with each
other.
And that I haven't been honest with myself."
The fallout from their break-up leads Lara
Jean to briefly kiss John Ambrose at the Belleview
ball, in a moment which feels straight out
of one of the romance novels LJ loves so much.
But this is reality, not fantasy, and she
quickly realises she doesn't like him that
way.
"We kissed.
But I wanted him to be someone else."
And Stormy helps her understand that:
"Sometimes you have to kiss the wrong man
to know what's right."
Although LJ and John are [theoretically] more
compatible in terms of their shared interests,
outlook and temperament, it's Peter who offers
Lara Jean something more and gives her scope
for personal development and growth.
As Lana Condor says, "Lara Jean […] needs
to be pushed to expand into different spaces
of her personality, and that's what Peter
does, even though he presents the risk of
breaking her heart."
In fact, according to the sequel's director,
Lara Jean and Peter's promise to never hurt
each other was something that was impossible
to keep, a youthful but naïve vow, and when
they go through that in this movie, they actually
emerge stronger.
"Peter and I promised not to break each other's
hearts."
"Oh, honey, you're always breaking someone's
heart, or they're breaking yours."
"Well, isn't there a way to both get out unscathed?"
"Not if you're doing it right."
"Break my heart into a thousand pieces.
Do whatever you want."
Also at the heart of the sequel is a resolution
to the question of whether it's OK to have
feelings for more than one person.
After her break-up with Peter, Lara Jean realises
there's a concept from her Korean heritage
that can help her with this:
"It's called jung.
It's the connection between two people that
can't be severed.
Even when love turns to hate, you will always
have tenderness in your heart for them."
LJ notices that even though they're no longer
friends, she and Gen still have jung.
And she realises that Peter also has it with
Gen and that she should stop blaming him for
it.
This moment of self-discovery helps her reconcile
with Genevieve, and in the next scene when
Lara Jean sees her father and Mrs Rothschild
together, she finally realises it's possible
for him to find love with someone else, but
still hold affection for their mother.
Likewise, by the end of the movie, LJ recognises
that it's possible to love two people as the
same time, albeit in different ways.
As Lana Condor said in an interview with EW,
LJ's deep love for John can be confusing "because
you're like, 'Oh man, do I love him or do
I love him as a friend?'"
The concept of jung though means that Lara
Jean doesn't have to forsake her deep affection
for John in order to remain faithful to Peter.
"Are we good John Ambrose?
We've always been good."
Or as the movie's director puts it, "much
of what the sequel is about is Lara Jean learning
to confront her own truth without losing her
optimistic outlook on love."
"It's not a cynical view of romance or adolescence.
It's an earnest, fun, passionate presentation
of it."
Now, what do you think about the sequel and
how it handled the love triangle?
And are you glad LJ ended up back with Peter
or would you have preferred John Ambrose?
Comment with your thoughts below.
If you enjoyed this, be sure to subscribe
for all my new videos including Netflix's
Sabrina, You, Locke and Key, and Stranger
Things.
Tap left for my next video or tap right for
another video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!